[Music]
there's this dude a competitor a
competitor in Chinese chess says he has
sued the National Association in China
for mental distress after he was
stripped of a title for drinking alcohol
and shading in the bathtub of of his
hotel at a recent
competition wait you can't [__] at your
hotel can [__] in your bathtub in the
bathtub oh the bathtub what if you [__]
in the bathtub but then you push it down
with your feet is that what you did
evidence yeah I think that there was
evidence didn't you do something close
to this yeah B did what where in a
shower oh at Jill's House yeah yeah he
didn't just push it down his feet he had
to like fingernail scrape it off of the
[__] pile had [__] stomach
poisoning whatever the [__] it was it
bounced off the bathtub and went to the
tile cuz she bounc so why did you act
dig it you're like well I didn't do this
[__] like yeah I was scraping out the
wall my fingernails sure well that was
out of my bodily control this is sounded
like he was doing it on purpose I never
did on purpose gas yeah PSI is that yeah
dude PSI dude it might be a simple
mistake had a fullback blowout he
probably never seen a western bathroom
before so he [__] in a toilet and
showered in a toilet I mean [__] in the
bathtub and showered in the toilet who
reported that I like [__] in the toilet
and shower yeah who who in his room
reported that what a [__] animal okay
so so this guy's name is Yan
changlong he doesn't deny what happened
but wrote in a civil complaint this week
that he drank a moderate amount of beer
to celebrate his win with other players
and I own it and that some food had
caused stomach problems and he couldn't
make it to the toilet in time this is
your that's so funny how can you make it
to the bathtub but not the toilet
they're right there
what right next to you all right cancel
him yep he goes oh I don't know what to
do maybe he turned the wrong way it's
like a matter of a split second
difference the complaint came you got to
clean up you got to clean up yeah oh he
left it huh the complaint came one week
after a social media post by the Chinese
shangi Association Shang shut up shut up
that's not what it's called oh you know
what that's Chinese chess shangi see
yeah yeah all right that described the
drinking and defecation it said an
investigation had found that Yan damaged
Hotel property violated public order and
good behavior and had a negative impact
on the tournament why didn't he clean it
it's not that hard where do you go back
it's your own
[__] he just left it there for the
[__] yeah run the foset just yeah he
left it there for the that's [__] up I
think you should be disqualified for
that I do too for being a filthy [__]
animal so that affected the tournament
itself they stripped him of his title
yeah it's bad it's bad conduct dude but
the Kaka has nothing to do with his
title but the Yan's complaint which
demands that the association apologize
restore his reputation in the media and
pay him $100,000 Yan which is $4,000 in
Damages he might win this he might
really win that how do he Resto it's
hard to say though because in China if
an organization or Association usually
associated with the government wants to
make an example of you in order to keep
like The Prestige of something a certain
way and Chinese chess is a Chinese game
too so they probably have a lot of
national pride in their own games it's
not like regular chess or like soccer or
something like that but the Chinese
chess Pride isn't it just [__]
marbles but it's Chinese and it's not
marbles it's like little circular pog IL
it's similar to regular like a bishop
Queen it's the same no I played Chinese
chess before it's the triangle and you
put the marel no that's Chinese checkers
chines one on the little the one that's
on a star yeah the ttin little ttin yeah
it's like a star David chines you play
with five other players it has
characters on it what the [__] is that
thing myob it's my oh yeah my you're
being racist right now no that's Chinese
Tic Tac Toe bro d That's Chinese Chinese
chest is actually really fun no no it's
like yeah it's like regular chest
there's a bishop [__] all know the
all the different the same ones pawns
it's just it's literally like just chess
but just slightly different very very
yeah but how can you tell the difference
of the pieces they're all squares they
they have characters on them they I
don't read
Chinese but isn't it kind of unrelated
this this to me would be like if Conor
McGregor's [__] in a bathtub and then
the UFC strips him of his title that's
nuts to me right but I think it's
different because you know how China is
China China has like
like you for example there was um but he
didn't test positive for steroids or
something like there was a dude who won
the rap of China right like this whole
[__] a giant TV show about like
finding rappers and stuff right and then
the second he cheated or like he he had
adultery with an a Chinese actress who
has like a husband and children damn
because of that the government stepped
in and wanted to make example of hip-hop
culture in general and then they banned
tattoos and rap from all TV and they
shut down everything they took all his
music off everything because because it
was about keeping the nation's pride and
imagery at like a Prestige type that's
true cuz then people will look at this
and be like see Chinese people always
[__] in [__] bathtubs and [__] it
makes the Chinese people yeah so if a
dud what quest won number one which they
did but then they stri got stripped the
tow cuz you guys are back filling
toilets up right backing all the toilets
up in the whole
hotel that's that's what that's what
reminded me like when you said that
because at first I'm like maybe he's
suing because you can only strip
someone's title away if you already had
a precedent in the paperwork that said
any it's like a conduct agreement if
that's not there then I could see him
suing and going well you can't strip me
because it didn't say you could do that
when I signed on but because China is a
communist country doesn't [__] matter
they can come in and be like well here's
what's happening and the whole studio
has to follow it yeah yeah they just add
new rules and you're supposed to have
follow it it's that it's that that's
exactly what it is cuz even when I was
working on that show they the the show
that I was on had a rep from the
government and randomly there were just
like no dyed hair Exposed on camera that
was it everyone's like oh [__] well I
got to put a hat on now yeah the day
that that happened while I was trying to
makeup people came to my hotel room and
had to [__] put makeup all over my
tattoos and I was like a background
choreographer you know what I mean and
it's like wait why are there no tattoos
the show doesn't give a [__] it's just
now there's like a [__] thing above
it government won't let you have tattoos
on TV that's [__] crazy I can see the
story having got so big that now the
government's like you're not going to
win this [__] game yeah imagine it
going viral on Chinese social media like
this guy's [__] in the bathtub you know
what I mean he's the winner of Chinese
chess and it's like no we can't have
that and if China's good at anything
it's showing the rest of the country
that you're not going to win when you
fight
back that's probably the best point yeah
that's why they about to take over uh
Thailand Taiwan sorry my bad thank you
you almost caused the War
bro some people really think this is
actual news my bad my bad yeah a lot of
people think this is real news so and
they take it real seriously at the
comments so you got to be careful I tell
no I know not tell you got to apologize
right now take it back to Taiwan goe I'm
not even gonna be in this video because
I'm G to be Associated uh my bad thail
that was really good thank you Taiwan
you said my bad Thailand well well-
handed yeah I think you're not wrong I
think it's called Taiwan land that's a
very s so he shortened it by Thailand
hey thanks Joel you [__] understood
jeez I was trying to say that the whole
time I don't think that is pretty
embarrassing imagining that you're like
the story of you having [__] in the
bathtub got to a global level like
this be funny kind of gives you
character you're like damn the [__]
chess champion a [__] yeah that's
crazy bathtub [__] yay I still don't
understand his excuse I could have make
it to the toilet yeah that part got me
yeah it is kind of we never know the
circumstances maybe it was like a really
big hotel room in the bathtu was really
far from the
toilet it was Bart's actual same story
where he was taking the shower and he
was sick and he just [__] it while he
was taking a shower but would the [__]
would have went down the tub human
thinger maybe he's thinking his M it's
going to [__] explode and technically
the toilet hole is like this big but the
bathtub is like there's a lot of space
it's better to explode into a smaller
hole so you keep it contained yeah but
you got to stomp it down if it's a real
chunky Bud last time that you could last
time you couldn't make it to to the
toilet oh disaster was it was the was
the time window so close that if you had
[__] up and accidentally ended up on
the tub there' be no time to switch back
to
toilet yeah you can't if it goes it
sprays that might be what happened then
maybe he just we have an expert cuz
otherwise the comments would be calling
us out for like just
misinformation we get a guy who knows I
know why didn't he clean it that's true
that's dirty man well if it's at a hotel
do you guys clean everything no if I
spray [__] everywhere if I yeah if I did
[__] on theb [__] I feel bad hey
remember the story I told you my my ex
who had [__] on the bed I I didn't clean
that oh you're mean calleded it up and I
went to the laundry and I stuffed it
behind the [__] corn you know what in
a sense that's cleaning that's still
clean it's not in your room disolving
that's not cleaning you put it on the
janitor yeah I got someone else fired
you didn't take the poop and put on the
TV I got a guy fired and then deported
like why why would a bed sheet be behind
the trash can you're [__] fire get
the [__] out of job yeah come on and why
take [__] in it you know what I mean you
stole the bed sheet you put the tured
here so you could leave with
it it was my dream to own a hotel but I
feel like it's probably one of the most
disgusting things people dying people
overdosing people ksing there people
[__] and coming everywhere [__] on
bed come on the ceiling just so you
can't yeah so you can say you can't
active shooter active shooter poop
party remember uh how dietrix was
telling us he he used to work as a a
motel cleaner oh [__] in Sacramento and
he said that uh they he would come in
there and there would just be like
cocaine there'd be blood all over the
wall and he said he said the what him
and his friend would do that were
working for that company they would they
would just pee on everything cuz if it's
piss they have to get a different
cleaner because it's bio or something oh
[__] so they would just put their own
pee on the so if they see if they saw
cocaine they're like [__] I piss on the
cocaine they piss on it sh because then
you have to you have to bring in a
different qualified uh cleaner what if
it was a murder case like oh DS his DNA
with the blood dude that's actually
really scary yeah D there's just [__]
a chopped head a bunch of blood they I
don't want to clean this let me pee all
over
it you know those those qualified
cleaners those crime scene cleaners we
were looking into actually getting one
of those businesses they make money why
didn't you want to do it and make it all
fale to provide opportunity yeah I think
it's it's cuz they can't pee on stuff as
easily job yo I'll be I I'll do it they
can't just give me a pressure washer
there you go I'll do
it